Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wir sitzen vor dem Salon, um uns darüber zu verständigen, wie blöd wir sind. Nein, wer ist blöd? Irgendwer ist blöd. Wir klären es auf im Februar.
Ja, wir sind vielleicht zu dumm für die Demokratie. Da ist immerhin ein Fragezeichen dahinter. So heißt aber das neue Buch von Mark Schiritz, der bei der Zeit ist und der jetzt bei Drömer dieses Buch herausbringt, zu dumm für die Demokratie. Und der Untertitel lautet, wie wir die liberale Ordnung schützen, wenn der Wille des Volkes gefährlich wird. Wir sind ja schon sehr versiert in Debatten um die Demokratie. Du bist ja für ein Familien- oder Kinderwahlrecht. Wir haben das ausführlich debattiert. Das wird auch in deinem Buch noch einmal Thema sein. Wir hatten aber auch Debatten darüber, ob man überhaupt sagen kann, dass es einen Demokratieverfall gibt, denn es wird ja wahnsinnig viel gewählt. Sagt zum Beispiel Philipp Mahno. Oder haben wir, wie Veit Selk meint, eine Demokratiedämmerung. Er verwies ja in einem Kapitel zum Beispiel darauf, dass ganz viele Menschen in Deutschland, sehr viele Erwachsene, nicht in der Lage sind, über das Niveau eines Viertklässlers hinaus Texte zu verstehen oder selbst zu schreiben. Was dann auch bedeutet, können diese Leute überhaupt fähig sein zu entscheiden, welches Wahlprogramm mir am besten gefällt. Müsste man also vielleicht einen Demokratieführerschein oder etwas einfordern? Das ist also diese Frage, die uns ja alle irgendwie umtreibt. Und mir ist es jetzt noch mal die Tage so präsent geworden, dadurch, dass du hast es vielleicht auch gesehen, in den sozialen Medien ein Foto rumging von diesen Protesten in Risa gegen die AfD. Und auf einem Foto war Bundespräsident Steinmeier zu sehen, der im Anzug im Schneidersitz auf der Straße saß und darunter hunderte Kommentare. Da sieht man es wieder, der Bundespräsident ist gegen die Demokratie. Natürlich war das ein AI-generiertes Bild und es sah auch sofort so aus und man denkt sich ja auch, der Bundespräsident würde wohl nicht auf der Straße rumsitzen. Aber für diese Leute war das plötzlich die Realität und man denkt dann in dem Moment, ah ja, die gehen ja auch alle im Februar wählen. Hat also Mark Schieritz recht und was würde das denn bedeuten? Denn wenn Menschen zu dumm sind für die Demokratie, müsste man dann antidemokratisch gegen diese vorgehen. Muss man einen Unterschied machen zwischen Demos und Populous? Das sind schon sehr relevante Fragen.
Ja, ich finde das eh interessant. Heute ist der 20. Januar. Trump wird nachher vereidigt. Diese Zeremonie wird das erste Mal seit 50 Jahren wieder indoor stattfinden wegen Wetters. Jetzt könnten wir uns ja die Pointe erlauben. Angenommen, es wäre vor vier Jahren so kalt gewesen, wären die Leute auch alle zum Kapitol gegangen, hätte es dieses mega aufruhrische Ereignis gegeben, die Debatte bis heute. Dann inklusive dessen, was wir heute sehen, dass nämlich während der Wahlkämpfe regiert wird mit großen Ansagen, ihr macht jetzt Schluss in Gaza und Dollarwetter und so. Und dann während der Amtszeit wird Wahlkampf gemacht für die nächste. Du hast jetzt die AI-Sachen schon angesprochen. Es war ja ganz interessant, dass der amerikanische Wahlkampf relativ frei blieb von AI-Fakes. Aber wenn das Regierungshandeln so begleitet wird von den Regierenden, dann ist es natürlich eine andere Diskussion. Also alles verdreht sich und dieser Wetterhinweis, der dient auch dazu, wenn wir jetzt sagen, sind die Menschen zu doof für die Demokratie oder zu dumm? Da könnte man sagen, ja, kann schon irgendwie sein. Wir sind ja für vieles zu dumm. Also warum nicht auch für die Demokratie? Also wir laufen alle mit 30 Kilo Übergewicht rum und sterben zehn Jahre früher als nötig und keine Ahnung. Also es gibt ja ganz viele Sachen. Wir kaufen nur Scheiß, den wir nicht brauchen und so weiter. Also gesellschaftlich sind wir ja in ganz vielen Bereichen dumm und würden das da gar nicht. Jeder kokettiert damit. Mathematik, ja, da bin ich schon immer. Da war ich immer kleide holen und so. Aber bei der Demokratie nimmt das alles so super ernst, dass da alle super klug sind und vielleicht sind wir es einfach nicht. Und jetzt kann das Wetter oder die Dofheit einfach so eine externe Größe sein, die einfach neben unserer angedichteten Superintelligenz steht. Und meine Frage ist jetzt, wenn wir dieses Buch lesen, das kommt ja erst Anfang Februar aus, 3. Februar oder so, wir können es noch gar nicht lesen. Mark Schiritz als Autor schätze ich über alle Maßen. Und zwar vor allem durch diese Versuche inhaltlich noch aufzuklären. Also er kommt dann mit den, wer sind die Hartz-IV-Empfänger, wie verteilt sich was, was bedeutet Migration und so weiter und so fort. Jetzt heißt dieses Buch zu dumm für die Demokratie. Typischerweise schreibt man erst mal einen Text und danach kommt man mit dem Verlag so auf eine Diskussion, wie nennen wir denn das Buch. Meine Hoffnung ist, dass dieser Titel am Anfang stand und dann mit Text durchargumentiert wird. Und ich hoffe auch, dass wir eine ernsthafte und ehrliche Erklärung darüber kriegen, wie dumm wir eigentlich sind, was die Demokratie angeht. Und es nicht wieder so halb gar und dann am Ende doch die Pointe, nee, nee, ist schon die beste Staatsform oder irgendso was Affirmatives, sondern ich will jetzt das All-In-Zeitalter auch da eingeläutet wissen.
Er ist ja ein Liberaler, also in dem Sinne nicht, dass er FDP-Anhänger ist, sondern liberal, dass er die liberale Demokratie für besonders schützenswert hält. Und die Frage ist natürlich, zu welcher Kritik der liberalen Demokratie ist er dann auch bereit? Ich habe schon mal in das Buch rein gesehen. Es gibt ja Leseprom, da ist dann schon gleich am Anfang Georg Büchner's Dantons Tod zitiert. Da geht es schon darum, was ist eigentlich der Wille des Volkes. Und dann beginnt das erste Kapitel damit, dass Hillary Clinton 2016 eine Rede hält und von den Entbehrlichen von dem Basket of Deplorables spricht. Und die Frage ist natürlich, alle haben sich darüber aufgeregt, inwieweit hatte sie Recht, auch wenn ihr das sicherlich die Wahlergebnisse verhagelt hat. Und was bedeutet das aber, wenn man sagt sie hat Recht über die editäre Weltanschauung, die in Demokratien, in liberalen Demokratien vorherrschend ist. Also das ist ja ein ganz, ganz heiktes Feld, in dem man sich da tummelt. Schön an dem Buch finde ich auch, dass es kurz ist. Und das meine ich jetzt nicht ironisch, sondern ich finde es einfach gut, dass diese Frage man jetzt einmal in 160 Seiten beantworten möchte und nicht sagt, ich muss da mal 1000 Seiten erzählen. Und was hat Aristoteles schon dazu gesagt? Und Augustinus hatte folgendes Verhältnis dazu, sondern ich glaube hier springen wir direkt in die Gegenwart. Also 2016 an Hillary Clinton und wie man so dem Inhaltsverzeichnis entnehmen kann, geht es auch genauso weiter dann. Es geht auch um den Stadt-Land-Konflikt, um ja die mediale Berichterstattung über Politik. Und ich glaube, da sind wir so mitten drin, weil er es auch als Autor, als Journalist ist. Und ich glaube, es ist genau die richtige Grundlage, die wir benötigen dann für das Ergebnis der Bundestagswahl. Denn egal wie diese ausgehen wird, wir können ja jetzt schon mit Gewissheit sagen, wir werden alle nicht danach jubeln und sagen, Mensch, das war ja richtig gut, da haben wir ja alle wahnsinnig Glück gehabt, das war toll. Das ist ja nicht der Fall.
Ja, wir sind gespannt. Das Qualitätsmerkmal unter 200 Seiten gilt natürlich. Neu, das ist jetzt im KI-Zeitalter, lang kann jetzt jeder. Oles Buchen unter 200 Seiten, Mainz sind unter 200 Seiten, Mark Scheritz unter 200 Seiten, das ist das neue Format.
Ja, finde ich sehr gut. Wir sind also gespannt auf diese Lektüre. Wir werden dann im Salon auch noch bekannt geben, dass wir einmal wieder in die Oper gemeinsam gehen könnten. Da werden wir dann auch den Termin nennen. Und wir wollen noch zum Schluss darauf hinweisen, dass ihr diesen Podcast dadurch unterstützen könnt, dass ihr den Salon abonniert. Und tatsächlich bekam ich jetzt noch einmal von jemandem eine Nachricht, was denn eigentlich dieser Salon ist. So dieser Salon ist das Zusatzformat zu den neuen Zwanzigern. Das heißt, wir besprechen dort immer ein Buch, das wir gemeinsam gelesen haben. Dieses Mal wird es Marc Schiritz neues Buch sein. Und dann empfiehlt jeder von uns noch fünf weitere Texte. Dieser Salon dauert in der Regel drei oder vier Stunden. Wir diskutieren also sehr, sehr ausführlich über das eine Buch. Und dann machen wir unsere Empfehlungen. Das ist der Salon. Das ist der Zusatzinhalt. Und den kann man ganz einfach abonnieren. Wenn man zum Beispiel bei Apple ist, braucht man es nur anklicken. Und dann hat man es drin. Wenn man das anders hören möchte, was wir auch empfehlen, zum Beispiel über Steady, dann kann man auf neu20er.de gehen, geht auf den goldenen Button. Da kommt man zum Salon, kann sich auswählen, welche Mitgliedschaft man möchte. Ab drei Euro ist man dabei. Man kann auch über Spotify gleich zu diesem Button gelangen. Oder wer schon bei Patreon angemeldet ist, kann den Salon auch via Patreon buchen.
So ist es. Du hast alles gesagt. Das ist unsere kleine Paywall in unserem Safe Space. Als Angebot für die ganze Welt und jeden Einzelnen. Sehr gut.
Und dann hören wir uns am Ende des Monats. Ich bin gespannt, was du alles zu Trump zu sagen hast. Du verfolgst wahrscheinlich jede einzelne Minute.
Na mal sehen. Ich glaube, das ist ja nun wetterbedingt so abgespeckt, dass es wirklich nur die Rede ist. Mal gucken. Ja, wird auf jeden Fall interessant. Also heute wir schauen uns alle und machen uns dann am Monatsende unseren Reim darauf.
Bis dann.